[Applaudissements]
oh
l'unité du commonwealth n'a pas résisté
à la politique de ségrégation raciale
qui sévit en afrique du sud et qui
dresse une barrière de tous les instants
entre le monde des gens de couleur et
celui des plans
mis en accusation à londres par les
autres premiers ministres du
commonwealth le docteur vers word
malgré les efforts conciliateur de
monsieur macmillan annoncé le retrait de
son pays
la communauté britannique ne comprend
donc plus désormais l' empire que cecil
rhodes avait bâti sur l'or et le diamant
en des temps où l'attribution des lots
de prospection se faisait au plus rapide
à ce qu'ils atteignaient les premiers le
témoin
[Musique]
dans les villes modernes cependant sans
le travail fourni par les noirs
l'afrique du sud ne pourrait continuer à
être ce qu'elle est la première
productrice d'or du monde
e
[Musique]
elles ne pourraient non plus continuer
d'assurer une production de diamants qui
lui permet de faire la loi dans la
fixation des cours mondiaux
où
la défaite électorale du général smet
avait en effet laissé la voie libre à la
ségrégation raciale avec le docteur
madan puis le docteur vers word
engendrant des conflits sanglants dont
le docteur board lui même si les frais
l'année dernière la révolte des noirs a
été on s'en souvient noyer dans le sang
violences qui sont le contrepoint de la
politique raciale
l'union sud-africaine pourtant s'enferme
dans son système
hier les électeurs c'est à dire les
blancs doit être à une faible majorité
pour la république premier acte
d'indépendance vis-à-vis de la
grande-bretagne
aujourd'hui c'est l'exil volontaire hors
du commonwealth
[Musique]
en france la grève des fonctionnaires a
été très suivie c'est du moins
l'impression qu'on pouvait retirer de la
manifestation des agents de l'état à
paris rue de rivoli où il n'était pas
question d'essayer de circuler à cette
occasion les agents de police ont fait
l'apprentissage de leurs nouvelles
fonctions d'ange gardien de la presse
tout d'ailleurs s'est très bien passé
les manifestants se sont contentés de
programmer leurs revendications devant
le ministère des finances
dans la perspective de l'ouverture des
négociations sur les bords du lac léman
on attendait avec anxiété en algérie la
fin du ramadan mais alger comme le reste
du pays fut en fait exceptionnellement
calme place du gouvernement la foulée
coutaller conteur d'histoires et les
joueurs de flûte
[Musique]
en tunisie depuis le retour du président
bourguiba l'atmosphère était à
l'optimisme après une absence de trois
semaines marquée par la visite au
général de gaulle à paris le président
de cuba avait reçu dans sa capitale un
accueil triomphal
et la fin du ramadan de descoings sider
ici avec la décision du fln de faire le
voyage du lac léman
cette décision les membres du gpr aggasy
de bentobal et ferhat abbas devait la
communiqué au président de la république
tunisienne
la fere algérienne entre maintenant dans
une nouvelle phase
[Musique]
en effet pourquoi pas nous vivons comme
chacun sait les rats tomic l'ère
spatiale l'air magnétique alors tenus en
équilibre dans l'espace par deux
électroaimants le sculpteur takis touche
aujourd'hui à ceux qui étaient hier
l'impossible c'est du moins le sens
qu'il donne à son oeuvre de son perchoir
perdu dans son univers spatial
il communique son inspiration à des
disciples qu'ils formulent sur des
espaces déterminer la composition voulu
dont les éléments métalliques bien
entendu dessine sous l'action du champ
magnétique une mystérieuse symphonie
[Applaudissements]
oise audacieux peut être mais novateur
également cyril constantin bricoleur
acharné et inventeur à ses heures a
découvert son art en regardant un jour
un ouvrier se servir d'un pistolet métal
isr depuis dans son atelier
d'aix-les-bains lemaitre a mis au point
sa technique à l'aide d'un arsenal de
pistolets de chalumeau qui sont ses
pinceaux projetant sur son support les
méthodes son choix il obtient par
l'oxydation de ces derniers les couleurs
désirées
le maître ne s'en est d'ailleurs pas
tenu là pour faire vivre ces
chefs-d'oeuvre dont les reflets change
selon l'éclairage
il a construit un projecteur spécial
dont le jeu donne tout son sens à cette
oeuvre absolument incomparable
répétons nous pourquoi pas
[Musique]
on sait que les moeurs scolaires ont
admis aujourd'hui les classes de neige
ou le temps des écoliers venus des
villes se partage entre la poursuite des
études et l'initiation aux plaisirs du
ski c'est que l'école n'est plus ce
qu'elle était au temps de notre enfance
elle ne se contente plus de dispenser
l'instruction l entente y joindre dutil
principes de santé ainsi à l'école
primaire de vendre c'est aux tout-petits
qu'on a songé pour eux après le déjeuner
la classe se transforme en dortoir et
l'on peut penser que cette expérience
des classes de sieste destinées à
rétablir l'équilibré perturbé par la vie
moderne est appelé à un certain avenir
[Musique]
à la place des cantines les restaurants
d'enfants deviendront eux de véritables
classe de diététique ou en même temps
que les bonnes manières
les élèves apprendront à apprécier les
menus équilibrés et ce qui est important
les boissons sans danger on a songé
aussi à apprendre aux écoliers à lutter
contre la carie dentaire qui atteint en
france deux enfants sur trois au vésinet
une expérience est actuellement en cours
dirigés par le professeur el de
l'université de genève spécialiste de
médecine dentaire
cette expérience est appelée à approuver
l'action anti carrie d'un métal l'oeil
bien connu le fluor
en effet des expériences d'analogue
réalisés à l'étranger ont démontré
l'efficacité du fluor dans ce domaine
la visite en fin qu'a rendu le nouveau
ministre de l'éducation nationale
monsieur paye au lycée de
vitry-le-françois a mis au premier plan
une nouvelle technique pédagogique les
classes à mi temps qui verront les
élèves consacrer la moitié de la journée
à l'étude et l'autre moitié au sport non
l'école n'est plus ce qu'elle était elle
fait mieux
[Musique]
c'est maintenant devenu une tradition
l'élégance masculine subi le rythme des
saisons tout comme l'élégance féminine
et il n'est plus temps de faire la fine
bouche face au gilet de soi boutonnet en
travers qui nous guette au détour du
printemps ainsi en a décidé le groupe
des cinq dans la collection nous prépare
au petit audace des martingales et des
pantalons toujours sans revers mais
légèrement fendue sur le côté
[Musique]
serons nous condamner cet été à prendre
du galon et à nous laisser aller vers
ces délicieux couvrechef style tyrolien
modifié en paille tressée coup penchons
nous pour la tenue du gentleman cowboys
avec gilet bleu hérault bas de pantalons
relevés et ouvert sur le devant le plein
étaient des vacances quant à lui verra
le triomphe du blanc abondamment
galonnés avec chapeau un rapport c'est
pas esprit d'avant-garde trouveront
peut-être trop classique cette mode 61
les audaces ne manquerons pourtant pas
la garde robe masculine qui adapte avec
le smoking sport non plus chapeau façon
cow boy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]